[Music]
what do you think about the olympics so
far you've been watching i haven't
watched a single thing i just saw that
we lost to france and basketball
yeah we did does that mean we're out yep
i think it's like tournaments no way
really goodbye
they just don't give a [ __ ] about the
olympics at all
no it's so funny someone was like
they're just there to recruit each other
for next season yeah that's literally
yeah
it doesn't even matter
what events have you watched we have
some we have some i've been watching
everything actually surfing yesterday
was [ __ ] incredible it was the
semifinals and the finals first time
surfing's ever been in the olympics
that's cool
it was actually really cool um
skateboarding was dope yeah so we
watched we've been watching all the
diving all the swimming
shitty form right sorry okay i'll let it
go i'll let it go i'll let it go i'll
let it go
um can we we have some olympic some
olympic fails
why don't we pull those up let's watch a
couple of them actually the [ __ ]
i even if you play it i can't even see
what is happening
i know why why is it so bad
because it's remote all right let's take
a look at these olympic fails olympic
failed
what do we got
it's literally not moving for me i just
saw oh i just seen like
i'm just seeing butt probably see her
[Music]
i just see frozen butt crack
wait yeah let's just watch it on our own
okay
damn this is like year one of the
podcast
i got a hat on i just played it we're
watching videos from our phones
oh damn
that was kind of a fail honestly
um where did where's that honestly that
was sloppy
okay
olympic oh yeah there's like the olympic
robot
there's a lot of olympic
[ __ ]
okay let me let me peep this gymnastics
fail real quick
i'm late to it
okay boom that wasn't even that bad we
just kind of like landed this is pretty
pretty [ __ ] for him yeah honestly you
know what let's just do this next next
week when we can watch them together
yeah
um
i will say this though
i think that if you
didn't know about skateboarding at all
and you watched
skateboarding at the olympics you'd be
like
these are the best skateboarders on
earth
like they didn't half the guys didn't
land a single thing
i wonder why the canadian dude in the
finals
his score i have a screenshot of his
scores because they're all zeros
it's so funny but it's like that's i if
you know skateboarding you know there's
like
you know it takes like
months for dudes to film
parts for their skate movies because
escape films whatever you [ __ ] call
them because you like it takes a while
to land every trick you know what i'm
saying for their you know their skate
media they're skating media
just take months to create a skating
video tape
oh
cody's killed over on my screen
let's narrate this
cody is reaching into his drawer and
he's pulled out a can of nos
looks like it's about 10 liters don't do
drugs kids
yeah the olympics have been good
honestly
i'll try to consider i
i kind of i kind of love the olympics to
be honest oh you're an olympic stand now
yeah i am name five events dude
easy
don't look at the sheet don't don't look
at it
i'm not i'm not i'll do my eyes closed
good
oh i don't know
artistic swimming
easy
um rhythmic gymnastics
shot put
[Music]
paintball
[Music]
no that's not one right
doesn't matter typical guy
only events you like are women dancing
around and shooting balls nice dude
nice
are you even watching the olympics are
you just
using this as a little bit of a medium
for you know
you're trying for spanking
yeah no i'm not spank off the olympics
there's too much skill involved
[Laughter]
in the olympics not spanking off to the
olympics
you really got to get in a good head
space to jack off to the olympics
[Laughter]
mentally it takes like a lot of effort
to just be able to jack off to the
olympics you know
yeah tough man olympic jazz super tough
to jerk off to decathlon yeah
you don't even know an olympic jack to
the javelin it's just there's not a lot
to work with you know yeah it's like
maybe 10
physical body 90
[ __ ] in the air
yeah
it's super tough i tried jerking off to
uh
bad badminton the other day
couldn't do it
to olympic badminton or were you just
looking at your badminton set
it's badminton it's not badminton why
does everyone say that badminton
yeah that's that's what we say badminton
it's badminton sounds like a city in
canada
yeah those boys are from badminton
edmonton
coming from from badminton eh
yeah so what what events are this week
do you know off the top of your head off
top uh more diving okay diving every
night honestly
until like the weekend
sick um
i don't know what else is on i'm having
a little olympics
you know little party tonight then i'm
gonna just do it
oh yeah dude i'll come through for sure
bro you know come through and breathe
all over your [ __ ] okay i'm down
cool
uh you know since since for the past two
hours we've just been getting mad about
comments
can i read one that like kind of made me
laugh
yeah and it hurt a little bit as well
okay someone was like
lol noel you make everything about
yourself but so do i
[Laughter]
so a couple things work and they're like
one it's very hilarious to also be like
i do too because they just they just did
that
yeah all right
also too i'm like
that's something i've been really
sensitive about recently
i like really hate when i do that i've
been trying to like really stop doing
that just you know therapy and all that
[ __ ] yeah so i felt kind of bad reading
that but then also i thought
isn't it kind of like inherently part of
the job right like you come here and
like you have life experiences you're
trying to like create entertainment so
don't you inherently kind of have to
talk about your own stuff god dude
again
you're just making this about you
sorry you're right
you're right you're right it is no it is
it is
it is
you know it's it's just you know
yeah
so yeah i know you have coveted but let
me tell you what i think i would be like
if i had
yeah
exactly that's cool man i would do covet
better than you honestly
anyway yeah honestly honestly
poor form seriously your coven form
sucks
you're you're shitty at having coveted
honestly you're coveted like isn't even
that sympathy inducing like
[Laughter]
the way you do covet is just like kind
of [ __ ] boring honestly it's pathetic
honestly
you